welcome to this meeting of
the baba district council cabinet i am
councillor john ward
leader of baber district council may i
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not
post comments or questions please note
that messages in the chat panel
can be viewed by people watching the
live broadcast
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council who have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
until the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded
i will now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members
we have councillor mccraw in attendance
also attending this evening
are the chief executive the strategic
director and the monitoring officer
thank you thank you claire can i now
move to the agenda please
so item one is apologies for absence
non-received chair thank you item two
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members
are there any to declare
no okay here we have councillor osborne
sorry i didn't see that sorry yeah thank
you thank you mr chairman and just to
declare that i'm a trustee of the
citizens advice
ready for when we do the draft budget
thank you
okay thank you item three
is paper bca 2017 the confirmation of
the minutes of the meeting of the
cabinet
held on the 10th of december 2020
and these are on pages 7 to 14
of your report i'll just go through them
page by page stop me if you have any
comment or question
page seven page eight
page nine
council osborne yeah thank you mr
chairman
yeah on uh page nine uh 32.6
um councillor arthi asked about our
housing stock numbers
if i could just clarify that briefly in
april 2015
we had a housing stock of 3441.
as at today we have 3568
and that includes those we have
completed on but not
are currently occupied and also we've
got a lot more coming through the
pipeline within the next six or seven
months
thank you mr chairman thank you
counselor
right moving on then oh cassellarthy
um yeah well it's actually just on that
point um i think
what we were expecting was a 10-year
schedule of housing stock
numbers um when i asked the question
at the last meeting um i was referring
to
the 30-year business plan which i think
was the 2017-2047 business plan
um which is published on our website uh
the
the idea of getting um a schedule for
the last 10 years
and something that we can continue to
update is because we've got an
ambition to increase our housing stock
um
and what i was rather hoping for was a
schedule that would show
um how our stock has been declining
um because of right to buy and um
the the lack of new council stock and
i was rather hoping that it would start
to show um
an increase so if you like the graph
starts to climb again
um as as we fulfill our ambition to
increase our stock by the acquisition
and building
um of new council accommodation so i
would still like to
to see that schedule prepared um
in our business plan um the stock was
actually
split uh across several different
headings there was general needs
sheltered
shared ownership leasehold and temporary
accommodation
and it in the table it also
gave us figures for bungalows flats and
houses
so i thought that that way of showing it
was quite good
and it would be quite nice if we could
have historic figures
and be kept up to date with annual
figures
as we move forward thank you okay uh
thank you councillor arthur yeah and the
um
the numbers that council osborne
presented do show an increase but
um uh the the initial decline and then
subsequent rise which
um uh up to the present time which
you're referring to um we will need to
to
present that um the business plan is
going to be updated um this year in the
first part of this year
so um by the time that comes to cabinet
and and council um i guess in the summer
summertime
then certainly that they'll be the
up-to-date um
information and showing the level of
detail that you're expecting
um moving on uh page 10
page 11. page 12
page 13 and
page 14.
if there are no further comments on the
minutes
may i have a proposal please
counselor halt and a second or is that a
comment castle
just a comment if i could um
[Music]
35.9 i did ask um
if clive could get confirmation as to
whether there'd be mobile
cctv cc tv cameras
and i don't think we've had a response
to that as yet
right okay um we will have to
take that offline and make sure we do
get a response to that yeah
thank you thank you so may i have a
proposal please
counselorathy well i need to say that i
can answer that now there will
be okay there will be mobile units
available yes
right thank you would you like to
propose the minutes cursor i think while
you're there
um i'll happily do that yes and may i
have
a second to please counsel the whole
second then
thank you uh now ask the governor's
officer to conduct the vote please
thank you chair members if you could
access the vote on your mod gov
app the vote for this item will now show
in blue
thank you chair that's eight votes for
that's unanimous
thank you claire right
moving on then uh the minutes of the
meeting actually have been confirmed and
will be signed at the next practical
opportunity so um item four to receive
no notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
not received thank you item five
questions by councillors
none received thank you item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees
there were none chair thank you
item seven the forthcoming decisions
list does anyone have any comments about
this
the only thing that um i would like to
say
is that um that the schedules for
next month for both uh well for
cabinet next month but also council this
month will now as a result of um
the petition we've received um be uh
it will include debates about the
parking policy paper so the
that'll be added to the agenda for
council on the um 19th and
next month's cabinet back to next
month's cabin on the fourth
any other comments about the forthcoming
decisions list
if not um we'll move on to the next item
which is item eight paper 2018
the inter authority agreement between
baby
district council and mid suffolk
district council
i would like to to introduce paper bca
2018
the inter authority agreement between
baber and mitt suffolk
as councillors are aware we entered into
an inter-authority agreement
effectively a memorandum of
understanding between baber and
mid-suffolk councils
when we first started working together
in 2012.
this agreement enabled us to ensure that
all staff are able to work for both
councils
and integrate services much has changed
however over the
last nine years and so it is necessary
to refresh the agreement to ensure it
remains fit for purpose
the revised agreement has been developed
between our three statutory officers
i will reiterate as i know many people
are still a bit confused by this
that baba and mid suffolk although
working together very closely
are still two separate sovereign
authorities we have not merged
that disagreement is before us now and
must be approved by both cabinets
is testament to this fact i will now
move the recommendation at paragraph 3.1
of the report
that the revised inter-authority
agreement be approved and that the
leader be authorised to sign the
agreement on behalf of the council
i'd like to ask for a seconder and then
i'll ask the assistant director of law
and governance to summarize the changes
made to this new agreement and answer
any questions so may i have a second to
please
counselor busby yeah i'm happy to do
that chair
thank you emily over to you
thank you chair um the key changes are
listed in
paragraph 4.3 of the report but broadly
speaking
they are to reflect the change in
certain governance arrangements
and the structure of the councils
bearing in mind that we now operate the
cabinet and leader model of governance
and we've had the electoral review that
uh alters the
uh number of councillors in each
authority
um the other key change is that the
first inter-authority agreement was very
much about establishing
a working together arrangement between
the two councils
so it talked a lot about implementation
arrangements and integration
arrangements obviously we're now at a
stage where very much
that relationship has been solidified
and and continues to be an
ongoing relationship so the document's
been updated to reflect
that nature so taking it from a an
implementation document to a working
document
if you will i'm happy to take any uh
questions chair but hopefully that the
report clearly sets out
the key amendments thank you
thank you emily does anyone have any
questions
nope yep yep oh sorry sorry i'm just
looking at it wrong
doesn't come up on my screen
[Music]
counselor halt and then counselor arthi
yeah
4.3 of the documents
the really the last five bullet points
um requirement for the share costs
to be signed off by finance and leaders
should that not be a cabinet
decision or are we talking about just
small annual costs or are we talking
about
the actual split of the cost between the
two councils
um the integration arrangements
um for staff and
i'm not quite sure what that means uh
the removal of the transition
costs and the premises clauses again
there's no breakdown of what that means
and also the insertion of the clause um
on inquiries hearings are proceeding
investigations
i i i don't know what other members do
but i don't know what that means either
so
there's those last five bullet points
really
who can have some sort of explanation
and really is it
the leader's role and the s151 officer
or should it be the whole cabinet
making those cost decisions
emily can you pick up on on those points
please
yes of course chair and thank you for
the questions so um in terms of the
share of costs and that is a delegation
that falls with the section 151 officer
and they have the ability to review that
those costs
and what we're doing here is we're
reflecting the move to a cabinet model
by including the leader and the relevant
cabinet members
in that discussion um of course
ultimately
the the decision around a proportion of
costs and budget
comes through to full council in any
case
but this is just the annual review in
terms of the split
of any costs between the two authorities
the um replacement of the provisions
around staff integration is just going
back to the fact that this document was
prepared in 2011. signed in 2012
when we were going through the process
of integrating our two
workforces into a single workforce
serving both councils so
that is superseded now because that was
very much the transit
the transition arrangements about
bringing the two workforces together
and obviously we now have the section
113 agreement
which deals with the split of or the
shared use of staff across both
authorities uh the um transition costs
and premises clauses are just
essentially out of date now because they
were just for those transition
arrangements um so again it was about
how we would use
premises that each council owned at the
time
and the transition costs were purely
about the costs related to that
integration exercise
um and the insertion on clauses of of
clauses on inquiries hearings
proceedings and investigations
to be honest that's a kind of uh
bolstering clause so it's just to add
additional weight to the agreement
around how we
deal with investigations and hearings
that affect
one or other of the sovereign council so
it's a
if you like and to put it clearly it's a
tidying up clause to make sure we've got
provision there to say
this is how we will work if one or other
of the sovereign
authorities is is subject to proceedings
hopefully that helps to it's just the
simultaneous cabinet meetings
um that's an insertion there i mean it's
something we have
been doing um what
ramifications has that got because
certainly from a baby point of view
certainly
amongst members it's not something we
always want to have uh happen but uh
are we going down the road that it will
happen and that's it because
that again takes away our sovereignty if
we're not able to have
our own cabinet meetings and not
simultaneous ones
uh we will have a mixture of the two
councilor halt um
what does that really assertion of
provisions for aligned simultaneous
cabinet meetings
why do we need that chair if i can
if i can reply to that one again uh
councillor it's really just um kind of
reflecting the the practice that we've
adopted recently of holding
two sovereign cabinet meetings at the
same place
uh and at the same time um you know
in it's it's kind of a it's a different
thing now we're in a virtual world isn't
it so because at the same place doesn't
quite have the same meaning
but you've always continued to have
sovereign cabinet meetings
we've just decided to hold them um
together
at the same place at the same time and
so this just really reflects in that
document it doesn't
um it doesn't mean that we are committed
to always having simultaneous cabinet
meetings and
obviously we'll see that moving through
the budget process and indeed this
evening's meeting
is a separate one as well i think it's
it's already
always worried to hear the fact that
you've agreed it but it's really down to
us members to agree
so i take your point but um i hope that
you respect what members want because we
are here to uh
make those decisions not offices thank
you
thank you counselor counselor arthi yeah
it's a
question for emily um about review
um because the document talks about
periodic review
um and 2.1 um
defines the term as being in force until
termination
um but when emily spoke she's she spoke
about
annual review um so
i'm i'm just wondering are we
will this be reviewed annually um is
there any
um provision for a periodic review
at any particular time or is this likely
to just sort of hang around for another
eight years
until somebody decides that it's about
time we updated it
chair i'm happy to answer that question
so the annual review that i referred to
was around the share of costs which is
talked about
in section 6.3 of the agreement
and so that's the only place where we
specify an annual review
otherwise obviously the document would
need to be
reviewed any time that there was a
legislative change that impacted on the
agreement
or there was a change in the operation
of of the authorities
if there was a further governance change
for example we would
review it at that stage but of course
there is the ability to review the
document
at any point that's deemed necessary by
the cabinet
or by one of the statutory officers
thank you emily councillor davis
um yeah it's really to irritate um
counselor holt's comments earlier on i i
agree with him
i'm a bit concerned about the wording
about the joint
uh briefings and cabinet meetings you
know
i think it should be clear that we have
separate ones whenever possible um and
the the joint member
cabinets should be an exception rather
than the rule
it really depends on the agenda
counselor um
as far as possible learn you will
appreciate that many items
are common for both councils and it does
make sense to
to debate them although we would if we
vote on them separately but to
be debate them together um simply to
hear the other
uh cabinet's views as as we're
deliberating
um and it makes for a more efficient and
tidy process but there are occasions
where
um the agendas do diverge considerably
and and consequently we we have separate
meetings as
we are having today
is that does that um answer your point
um it does and it doesn't it answers the
point and obviously
uh i can well understand why that clause
is in there but it's just the actual
word and makes it look as though
it's just normal to have joint briefings
and meetings all the time yeah and
it should be clear that we will have
them separate
well i i don't think the the way it's
worded doesn't um
uh it doesn't suggest that we're not
going to have separate meetings it just
makes the provision for for the
simultaneous meetings so um
arthur do you want to come in on this
point i was just
i was just going to try and give members
some reassurance and this is a document
that
that covers off your relationship with
with mid-suffolk um
and as emily says it updates because
really what we're doing is we're taking
a document that
dates back to 2011 in terms of when it
was drafted 2012 when it was adopted
and tried to better reflect current
times rather than nine years ago
but just to give you the reassurance in
terms of your meetings
you are and remain as the leader has
said an entirely
sovereign council so if you don't want
to have simultaneous meetings you won't
have simultaneous meetings
regardless of what it says in this
document all this document
recognizes is that it's possible for you
to have simultaneous meetings which is a
reflection of fact that you have had
simultaneous meetings
uh certainly over the course of the last
year if not longer
but it certainly does not tie your hands
in that regard and
as the monetary officers also said in
any event the document will be reviewed
on annual basis as well
so if there's any elements that you feel
uh over the course of the next 12 months
that need to be amended uh in 12 months
time then you you will obviously be able
to do so
accordingly thank you for that yeah i i
think that's a good reassurance because
i think it's important as well for our
residents to understand
that while we may have uh these joint
meetings
we are very separate and we come to the
decisions as as an independent baby
cabinet
yes absolutely yeah emily did you want
to come back on that as well
yeah thank you chair i just wanted to
add that um clearly the the constitution
sets out the framework for operating
um the decision-making structure of of
both councils so
uh that is the place where it talks
about two separate
um cabinets and and while you have that
that's that's still very clearly
um the the default position thank you
if there are no further questions from
cabinet members um councilman mccraw
do you have a question
uh thank you chair it's not exactly a
question more of an observation that
might assist on this point since uh
joint overview and scrutiny are another
group that commonly meet
together and we are aware of the
differences
in the governance of the two councils
there are also
differences of opinion and at times
those have been helpful
in uh coming to decisions most of the
time we're meeting because we are
dealing with
common cause common effects and and
common papers but there are differences
and
a very good example would be a recent uh
scrutiny process
on outside bodies and there are distinct
differences in the representation on
outside bodies
um and in that instance the two um
the two committees met in joint session
but we took separate votes
on and had separate proposals seconders
on each of those requiring us both to be
correct as independent
overview and scrutiny committees so that
we were absolutely certain that the
government's arrangements and any
differences between the members of
labour and the members of mid-suffolk in
terms of that question
were clearly defined and i just think i
think it's a
a practical matter rather than anything
else but the point of course is that
it's just a matter of our
maintaining the fact that we are
separate sovereign councils and
and and establishing that point there
are clear political differences between
the two councils and those must often be
reflected
both in scrutiny matters and in cabinet
matters
so just an observation i hope that might
help
thank you counselor right um
if there are no further questions from
members of the cabinet
um i will open it up for debate um
conscious of the fact that
we we have already uh included some some
debating points in the questions
so i'll just ask you each in in turn if
if you wish to say anything else
counselor arthi
um no thank you chairman i'm afraid to
say that i've i said my bit in the
questions yeah
that's okay don't worry castle busby
no i'm fine thank you councillor davis
no i've i've made my point thank you
councillor hold um two things i mean i
think
overall it shows the benefit of what's
been going on because it does mention in
appendix b that has been 13 million
pounds worth of savings
since this started so i think if you
look back at that then where would we be
without that
um and just one other thing in in i
think appendix b
point eight and nine or particularly
point nine it says major projects and
contracts
um the local authorities agree to notify
one another
with the value of an excess of fifty
thousand is that
really what we do do we have to get mid
suffix permission to or notify them i
don't really understand that one
um i didn't realize we'd have to get
their permission or
run it by them first it just seems a
rather odd thing to have in there
ah so did you want to respond to that
yeah emily may wish to come in as well
but but appendix b is the current
agreement
um so that's the one that will be
entirely disappearing
as a result of your decision today um i
haven't quickly checked back in terms of
whether or not that clause changes but
certainly
that's what disappears the whole
principle being that one of the reasons
you've been able to
save the kind of money that you have
between the two authorities is by
jointly working on things like contracts
so it's not so much that you get their
permission to do anything because as we
said earlier you're a sovereign
authority
able to do whatever you wish but clearly
if you wish to procure something for
example or enter into a contract
and if the other authority from a timing
perspective wishes to do so at the same
time
then there could be greater efficiency
and savings to be had as a result so
it's
it's more about making sure that you're
working together and grasping all of the
opportunities that may arise
it's certainly not about tying your
hands but i'll defer to emily if she's
been able to look
uh more quickly than i can through the
revised
uh document as to whether or not that's
something that's actually disappeared
within the new agreement or whether it's
still there in part
emily thanks chair um yeah it is in the
uh revised agreement um
and i would just echo uh the chief
executive's point
that it is not around getting permission
from the other partner to proceed
with with a value of in excess of 50 000
pounds
it is actually about that positive um
kind of ability and opportunity
to jointly share a procurement exercise
or jointly share in the contract so
i would absolutely say that it should be
seen as a positive clause
rather than a restrictive clause thank
you
thank you thank you and um and i would
just like to add the
13 million is actually um i think a bit
out of date um
the number that i have seen more
recently is nearer to 17 million so um
the savings are considerable and and
very beneficial for both councils
council malvisi do you have anything no
i don't have anything to ask everybody's
asked just ahead
for me okay thanks councillor osborne
no thank you mr chairman the the
questions have been have been asked what
i will say is though i do
agree with councillor davis and
councillor holt in regards to their
concerns about joint meetings
however i am reassured by the chief
execs comments that um
that will um will be um covered within
the new agreement so thank you mr
chairman
okay thank you and finally castle parker
nothing to add chairman thank you very
much okay thank you everyone
i'll now ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress in your mod gov app
just waiting for one vote
thank you that's eight votes for chair
that's unanimous
thank god could i just say it's quite
here mine was the late
vote and that was simply because
it was very slow so i do apologize for
that
okay thanks guys dorothy right moving on
the next paper is um item nine paper bca
2024
which is the wall is going to be the
town center parking
paper we have received a valid petition
regarding our parking tariff change
proposals
which means in accordance with our
constitution that full council must have
a chance to consider the matter
consequently i have decided after
speaking to the cabinet member for the
environment
that paper bca 2024 town centre parking
and baby
should be withdrawn today in my view it
would be
perverse for us to vote on this paper
before council has had a chance
to consider it and this will take place
at the next council meeting on 19th of
january
this will also enable the overview and
scrutiny committee to examine it at
their meeting on the day before
the paper will now come to cabinet on
4th of february for final determination
from feedback we have received most
notably from the two chambers of
commerce
and the sudbury town centre manager it
is clear that the principal concerns
of the length of free parking that will
remain and the implementation of the
changes during restrictions on movement
it was never the intention of
introducing this until the pandemic was
in permanent decline
hence our proposed july start date
however
the recent very serious resurgence
exacerbated by the new covert variant
will definitely delay recovery this year
and because of this
we were already considering a review of
the implementation date
we want to hear the views of overview
and scrutiny and council
on these matters please be assured we
are listening
thank you
so moving on to the next item on the
agenda
which is item 10 paper bca2021
fees and charges for the next financial
year 2021 to 2022.
i would like to introduce paper bca 2021
which is the fees and charges for 2021
to 22.
report presents the proposed fees and
charges for a range of services provided
by the council
including charges for services governed
by statute
and charges for discretionary services
these have been built into the draft
budget we will be considering later
this is the first time that these have
been considered separately from the
budget itself
to allow clarity and visibility of what
has been proposed
i would like to take the opportunity to
refer to some of the points raised in
section 4 of the report
as it says fees and charges are an
important source of income to the
council
along with our other income enabling us
to provide our services
in 2021 to 2022 baby's fees and charges
are budgeted at 4 million pounds which
is 20
which is 12 percent of the council's
gross expenditure
in order to sustain the delivery of
services in the future this revenue is
essential
indeed income generation of which these
are apart
is a key part of our medium-term
financial strategy
with reducing government funding the
stability and growth in the castle's
fees and charges is a major part of
delivering the strategy
as the administration we don't have the
luxury of continuing to ignore the
financial realities we face
and we will increasingly have to look at
how our discretionary services are
funded
section 5 of the report discusses the
impact of covert on our sales fees and
charges
and the main income streams where we
have suffered reductions
trade and garden waste long-term car
parking charges
and planning income all fees and charges
have been reviewed by budget holders as
part of the budget setting process
and their impact has been built into the
draft budget for 2021-22
appendix a provides a schedule of all
the proposed fees and charges while
appendix b
gives the estimated income breakdown by
service area
the summary of the changes to statutory
and discretionary charges is provided in
paragraph 6.8 and 6.9
although it must be noted that following
the withdrawal of the parking policy
paper
the short stay parking charges in the
table at paragraph 6.9
and the pending say section h cannot be
confirmed until cabin has finally
decided this matter
the revised section h you've been given
now has this table
removed although it is still present at
6.9
i would like to propose the
recommendation of the paragraph 3.1
that the proposed fees and charges for
2021 to 22
as shown in appendix they'd be approved
and may i have
a second to please
mr chairman liz malveezy here i'll
second
thank you very much castle i'm obviously
right
now um first of all
questions for cabinet members counselor
arthi do you have any questions
not at the moment thank you councillor
busby
uh no thanks chet councillor davis
no thank you councillor holt no not at
the moment thank you
councilman easy not at the moment thank
you
councillor osborne no not at the moment
thank you mr chairman
council parker
sorry chair for the delay uh no no
questions at the moment thank you
right um do any other counsellors as
present have any questions cancer mccraw
do you have any questions
apologies
no chair okay thank you
i'll now open the item up for debate
counselor arthi
gosh you're you're you're whizzing
through this aren't you
um i'm i'm not ready with anything for
debate just yet thanks oh okay
councillor busby
well just to make the point it just goes
to show all the kind of things that
we're in
involved in i mean it's pages and pages
of stuff
which i'm sure the the general public
probably wouldn't appreciate that we do
have to
uh have a handle on and uh
yeah it's the only other thing that i
would mention is that
i like round numbers so you know when
we've got something that's
1 141 pounds or something you think well
why couldn't it have been 1140 or
1150 or something you know but
i appreciate that people do these the
sums and multiply them by percentages
but
yeah and especially where um some of
them are set by central government we
just have to um
take what's given okay
um councillor davis no i i appreciate
the
um the accuracy of the officers that it
goes down to the the last pound soon
i'm i'm not worried about the uh it not
being quite
uh even if as it were no but no no other
questions or statement
thank you castle holt no not really john
i think just a comment that these
increases are obviously necessary
to help us with our budget and it's some
you know just fact of life that things
do go up and uh
we have to look at these and uh the
increases i think are fair thank you
okay thanks councilman vc i would second
um councillor hulk's comments
thank you councillor osborne no thank
you mr chairman
just i agree with councillor holt's
comments thank you okay
and finally council parker yeah again
nothing further to add um chair it's
very comprehensive report and
um as as councillor busby says it just
demonstrates the uh
the extent of the services that um that
we offer at baba thank you
thank you council arthur did you want me
to come back to you
um no thank you no thank you right well
thank you everyone i'll now ask the
governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members the vote should
now show
in progress on your app
thank you chair that's eight votes for
so that's carried
thank you claire right moving on then
item 11 paper bca 2022
transfer the council's vehicle fleet to
hydro treated vegetable oil diesel
or diesel worm substitute i'll now ask
the cabinet member for the environment
to introduce this report
council mauricio thank you very much mr
chairman
i'm just trying to pull it up on the
screen here
all the appendices that you had
ah
do you know what page it starts at
143 143 yes
thank you okay
right then when we committed to our
climate change action plan we identified
the areas where we could make
substantial inroads into our carbon
emissions total
baber's vehicle fleet including the
waste lorries accounts for
26 of our total emissions
and this can be almost eradicated by
converting our vehicles to
hvo renewable diesel fuel
hvo stands for hydro
i've lost it treated yeah
i'll come to it anyhow in my opening
we looked at other alternatives to help
decarbonize the fleet
such as electric biodiesel but we seem
to settle on hvo electric waste vehicles
are expensive to buy
and they don't prefer perform very well
in rural settings where they tend to run
out of charge
unlike their urban settings uh setting
environments
biodiesel is a diesel fuel replacement
commonly known as fatty acid methyl
ester
fame obtained from plants and vegetable
oils they can only be blended though
with conventional diesel to a maximum of
seven percent so not terribly cost
effective and don't actually produce
uh an impact on your emissions plant and
vegetable oils come from a variety of
sources
and what the climate change task force
did not want to do was to
source um a fuel that was derived from a
plant
that was farmed in other words taking
away
that agricultural resource from
providing food
for society um but just
providing um oil
depending on the provenance the biofuel
can save around 50 to 60 percent of the
emissions
resulting from a low ultra low sulfur
diesel fuel however they do have their
um
their own issues palm oil based fuels
block the vehicle's filters biodiesel
can oxidize if left too long in a
storage tank
biodiesels can have a corrosive effect
on
the um i think councilorathe raised it
at one of the task forces
on the o-rings doubt over traceability
is a big if
issue on um on fuel sourced outside
europe
and the main issue is the likelihood
that biodiesel contains palm
oil even from a waste cooking oil source
whilst it offers a cheap and versatile
feedstock the environmental and
ecological impact related to its
cultivation
has increasingly brought the
sustainability and long-term suitability
into question
and that left us with hydro-treated
vegetable oil
hvo as an alternative way
to produce a high quality bio bio-based
diesel fuel without compromising fuel
storage
engines exhaust after treatment devices
or exhaust emissions these fuels
are colloquially referred to as
renewable diesel fuels
instead of biodiesel chemically hvo's
are mixtures of fully saturated
hydrocarbons
and are free of sulfur and aromatics
unlike
fossil diesel cold properties of hvo can
be adjusted to meet the local
requirements by adjusting the severity
of the process
or by additional catalytic processing
this is therefore the recommended option
advice was sought from dennis eagle who
came and gave a very interesting
presentation and confirmed that the use
of hvo
in our fleet does not require engine
alterations
currently the fleet operates with fuel
cards and sources diesel from ordinary
fuel stations
therefore we will have to install a fuel
tank at a cost of fifty thousand pounds
a capital expenditure which could be
supported by sill
but as with any fuel prices
prices fluctuate and our research shows
that over the last three years
price has fluctuated from 15 pence to 26
vents per liter
thus we need to allocate an additional
revenue budget
of around 100 000 pounds this is
a higher cost than was anticipated
but it is also an easier high carbon
impact saving of 26
of our total carbon emissions in one
fell swoop
therefore mr chairman i fully endorse
this report
and urge the cabinet to vote in favor
thank you
thank you castler um i'd be happy to
second this report um
and so now i'll open up for questions
counselor arthi
um yeah i don't have any questions but i
do have um
i do have a contribution to the debate
in a little while okay
thank you councillor busby get you
no i don't have any questions thank you
councillor davis
no questions thank you councillor halt
i'll hold far for debate thank you okay
councillor osborne
sorry sorry mr chairman uh no not at
this point of time thank you
okay councillor parker uh no mr
no questions i'll join your debate thank
you okay
right um council mccraw do you have any
questions
nunchur thank you
right i'll um open it up for debate then
first of all counselor arthi
yeah okay well our waste fleet is um
is the the the emissions from our waste
fleet they are the single biggest
element of our carbon footprint as a
council
for the services we provide and what we
do
the option that we've um ended up
supporting um the one before you today
is the by far the best option
um for how things are at the moment
um there there is the possibility of
electric freighters um but um that's not
particularly well advanced at the moment
and as we all know there's talk of
things like hydrogen or hydrogen
in gas fuel and that isn't very
very well advanced either the big
advantage of this
is that our existing freighters can use
this fuel and it's not just
any alternative diesel fuel it's a
particular one and nest day
is mentioned in the report as the people
who provide the sort of treatment that's
necessary
so that these vehicles don't need any
modification
often with alternative diesel fuels um
from vegetable oil
uh you have to replace filters seals
and fuel lines as councilor mentioned
whereas with with this fuel we can
change
to the fuel and if for any reason there
was a problem with supply
um in the short term in order to keep
the the fleet on the road
we could revert back to fossil diesel if
we had to
so i'm very very supportive
and yeah i hope we hope we approve this
today
thank you councillor busby
no that was very informative thank you
councillor davis
no thank you yeah good
yeah i i just want to comment uh council
arthur's touch on the hydrogen side of
things and i think
eventually that will be the way that um
we will end up going
our fleet i think it's going to be
renewed in 2023
so this really is a short term quick fix
but it does come at a cost of course and
and again coming back to our budget
and all the pressures we have on our
budget it does go to show that um
the public needs to understand that the
biodiversity and the climate change
commitments that we are making
do come at a cost and that cost has to
be found again
um but if we are to hit those targets
and meet those
which which i'm sure the public want
thus to be
uh being seen to be hitting the climate
change commitment and the biodiversity
side of things
they have to appreciate that cost has to
be found and we have to find it
um so that was my comment really yes it
we need to do it we need to get the
fleet so it is cutting the emissions
down
but that cost has to be borne by someone
and we all have to find the money
yeah thank you absolutely it's uh well a
point very well made there
sam councillor osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman uh no
councillor holt and
councillor arthi as well has put uh two
really relevant points forward very well
so no i have nothing to add thank you
thank you council parker
uh well yeah um thank you councillor
arthur um
uh he sort of clarified most of the
points that i was i was going to pick up
on but
but i'm just wondering um chairman
obviously in the appendix
we've got an example of uh london taxi
company that are that are undertaking
this but where do we stand in terms of
local authorities
um who who else is um is doing this is
i'm just
generally interested to see if we've got
any any benchmarking but um
but of course long term i'm fully
supportive
thank you um i'm not sure um can i refer
liz yes customer vici do you have any
background information on other
suffolk authorities no i don't other
than the bureau of hackney
they they use hvo but in this region
perhaps um
cassandra clements the ad could uh can
comment
or ollie good evening cameron thank you
very much and thank you for the question
i think it's a really relevant one
and we have uh included the london
borough of hackney and that's actually
the closest
authority to us that has um undertaken
hbo a changeover to hbo
a lot of authorities we've seen are
watching
keenly on what are happening um with
other authorities
so um there's been a number of electric
vehicle
um trials that have gone on that haven't
necessarily proved um proved
beneficial at the moment um and i know
that um
east suffolk are currently exploring the
possibility of
biodiesel and i think our counselors
have outlined quite rightly why we would
prefer hbo over biodiesel
biodiesel um but there's not many
councils close to us i would say that
i've moved across and
you've seen some quite large strides in
scotland i would say of
move over to electric and hbo and
you know scottish parliament moved quite
quickly some time ago on
changing to more environmentally
friendly um
processes across the whole country but
there's nothing
um that close to us where that's uh
that's been taken on just yet thanks
guys
now it's clear that of the the various
options oh cassellarthy
do you want to say something well yes
chairman all i was going to say was
i mean please don't run away with the
idea that you know this is some sort of
crackpot thing that some professor has
come up with and we're trying it out
this is something that's been
investigated quite a lot on the
continent both for
road vehicles and also for the marine
application
um for diesel engines um in in
boats and ships so it's something that's
been well researched
um well evidenced and um yeah when we're
not
sort of the guinea pig here thanks
councillor
it's clear of the options uh hvo is is
certainly
the best because it is a much cleaner
fuel um
the the nature of the the treatment does
mean that there are
um far fewer pollutants you don't get
the the soots
that um would be produced and from
burning of unsaturated fuels um has
been mentioned uh lack of aromatic
hydrocarbons means that you don't have
the carcinogen problem
and it's interesting picking up on
councillor arthy's point about um
uh other users and he mentioned the
marine use i was uh watching the
mid-suffolk debate um at their cabinet
meeting
and uh councillor fleming mentioned that
before christmas
in in december a class 66 locomotive
ran from scuttle to south southampton on
a test run
and it was uh powered 100 pure hvo
so um the the usefulness of this product
is
is quite clear the only um comment i'd
make it at this stage is
clearly um as more and more
local authorities other organizations
see the benefits um
from a carbon reduction perspective
the demand is going to go up which will
affect the price
affect the availability so um i hope
that the
suppliers do do manage to uh ensure that
supply meets that increasing demand
okay then um if nobody else has has
anything
uh they wish to say i'll now ask the
government's officers to conduct the
electronic vote on on this item
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress on your app
thank you chair that's eight votes for
that's unanimous
okay then thank you moving on to item 12
paper bca 2019 the draft draft general
fund budget for 2021 to 2022 and the
four-year outlook
okay get this on my screen
i'm pleased to introduce report bca 2019
general fund budget for your outlook for
the next financial year
the report contains details of the draft
revenue and capital budgets and the
council's strategic financial aim
it will it will enable us today to
consider key aspects of the draft budget
and make any recommendations to feed
into the final budget report next month
it will also enable us to consider the
medium term position and ensure it is
sustainable
we've already had very helpful briefings
to facilitate our understanding of the
key elements of the budget and for your
outlook
this year we're in an an entirely
unforeseen
new and difficult situation the world is
a very different place than what it was
when i presented last year's budget
indeed the fact that we are doing this
online rather than in the council
chamber
is a very visible reminder of this it is
no exaggeration to say that we have had
to prepare this budget under the most
challenging of circumstances
the impact of curbing 19 has hit us on
top of having to respond to the
continuing fall in government support
for local authorities
the financial impact of covered this
year has been constantly evolving
and our initial very worrying assessment
has been ameliorated by
very very generous government support a
summary of the impact is provided in
paragraphs 4.5 to 4.10
the key numbers were presented in last
month's q2 monitoring report
and are summarized again here keeping
track of this has involved a lot of work
for the finance team
my mid-suffolk finance portfolio
colleague john whitehead and me
there is again uncertainty this year
over the core funding that will be
available over the medium term
the three-year comprehensive spending
review has been delayed and a one-year
review was published in october
focusing on continuing the response to
covert
financial support for curved pressures
will will continue into q1 of next year
as will the rural service delivery grant
additional support for businesses
announced on tuesday is also being
provided
the government has confirmed that the
fair funding review business rates
review
and business rates reset have been
deferred yet again
details of these and other features of
the spending review are provided in
paragraph 4.18 of the report
the recently announced provisional
financial settlement for 2021 to 2022
does give us additional funding of 724
000 pounds the details of the settlement
were provided in paragraphs 4.19 to 4.22
with table 1 providing a summary of the
financial impact
the settlement was only announced on the
17th of december and so there hasn't
been much time to incorporate it into
this budget
i'm indebted to catherine and the team
for getting us this far
but it is very much a draft and it will
change over the next few weeks
we have a sound medium term financial
strategy for the next four years that
responds effectively to the changing
funding landscape for local government
the strategic aims principles and
approach are set out in section 6 of the
report
along with a list of our achievements
during the current year
in summary and this is no change in
recent years we must continue with rfs
to become self-sufficient through
maximizing our income streams
continue to make efficiencies and
productivity savings
and continue to find new ways of working
the continuing delay to the
comprehensive spending review does make
our four-year outlook more uncertain
and given that this was already
challenging for us this is a worry
the general fund budget setting is just
a part of producing a medium-term
outlook for our finances which is both
sensible and sustainable
that's why during the lengthy budgeting
process we spend a considerable amount
of time on projecting four year
outlook the general fund budget requires
431
000 pounds or 52 percent of the
anticipated 2021-2022 new homes bonus
receipts
which will enable us to transfer the
rest to the new climate change and
biodiversity fund
details and new homes bonus funding are
provided in sections 8.6 to 8.10 of the
report
funding assumptions are shown in
paragraphs 8 11 to 8 14
with a four-year forecast included in
table six
for 2021 to 22 we will again be
increasing castle tax at the maximum
level allowed without requiring a
referendum
which is five pounds per year or two
point nine six percent for abandoned
property
and we have built in the same increase
for the three years following
the annual council tax for a band e
property will now be 173 pounds 86
there is also the assumption of a 1 tax
base increase
but for 2021 to 22 this is reduced as a
result of more use of the
local council tax reduction scheme
because of covert
and a lower collection rate the net
effect is that we are only forecasting a
total castle tax increase of
just 39 000 pounds
table seven of paragraph eight sixteen
provides a summary of the 2021-2022
budget
showing the net cost of the service
income and funding compared with the
previous year
although we are currently predicting a
surplus 711 000 pounds for 2020 to 21
the current year
but there is still a lot of uncertainty
regarding this and also
404 000 pounds for next year 2021 to
2022
these should be seen in the context of
our medium term outlook which will which
i will address in a moment
at this point i'd like to mention that
we are forecasting a total of 2.2
million pounds from our cifco
investments
an increase of 424 thousand pounds on
2020 to 2021
totally vindicating our investment
strategy which has ridden the covered
storm
and is providing much needed reliable
and necessary income
the 2021 to 2022 budget setting process
has again seen line-by-line budget
challenges to identify savings
but the cabinet has also had to make
some difficult decisions in addition to
approving the council tax increase
which i will now summarize we have had
to increase the garden waste collection
fee by two pound fifty per annum
we are suspending the under 17's free
holiday swimming for a year
saving 38 000 pounds we are relocating
and i stress relocating not closing
our customer access point in sudbury
saving 30 000 pounds
and lastly although not finalized yet we
are
thinking of introducing very modest
short-term parking charges
as the subsidy we are providing to our
car parks is no longer sustainable or
justifiable and they
must become cost neutral the full impact
of this will be
included in the final budget next month
assuming
um the the debate at council and then
the final decision at cabinet next month
as well
any change from from what we have
originally proposed
will however impact the forecast surplus
for 2021 to 2022
as stated earlier we are forecasting a
budget surplus of 404 000 pounds
the overall budget gap of the three
years from 2022 to 2023 is described in
sections 8.24 to 8.27
and amounts to a cumulative deficit of
1.77 million pounds
further significant income or savings or
both will be needed to address this
the reserve levels are detailed in
paragraph 7.2 table 3
we will use 381 000 pounds from error
earmark reserves
for specific service expenditure but
this will be offset by some transfers
in most notably the 404 thousand pounds
budget surplus
from the new homes burners receipts into
the new climate change and biodiversity
reserve
this means that we are able to increase
our reserves by modest amount
in 2021 to 22 although the
transformation fund will be slightly
lower
finally the capital program this is set
out in appendix a
and the plan spend 2021 to 2022 is 3.1
million pounds
the financing for this is shown in the
second table in the appendix
the major differences from this time
last year are that we will have
completed our cifco investments by the
end of the current financial year
and the bellevue capital investment is
no longer required now that the hotel
project will not take place in summary
we are currently in a good financial
position with a healthy level of
reserves
and helped by the funding we have
received from the government to mitigate
the financial impact of covid
however as i have said the medium-term
challenge is still significant
as we strive to become self-financing
over the next three years
i'd like to propose recommendations in
paragraph 3.1
to 3.2 of your report and
i'd like to have a a seconder but to
assist me in any questions arising we
have
um members of the finance team here
with us today um as i'm conscious that
there are going to be a lot of
complexities and technical matters
within the report
and appendices but hopefully between us
we will be able to clarify any issues
arising and i would finally like to
thank them all for the
huge amount of work they've done not
just in in preparing this budget but
throughout the year in in monitoring all
the
the
change implications of covid as they've
arisen
and the the increasing government
support that's come through to help
help with us with uh coping with those
covered issues
so may i have a second to please i'll
second
mr chairman thank you councilman rbc
thank you
so um firstly questions from cabinet
members
counselor arty any questions um i've
just got one
um i was looking back at the hbo
paper and i just wanted some
clarification i think on page 169 of
um the budget report um it mentions the
increased cost and
just to confirm that the figure that
we've put in there
is i think the highest end um of the
price differential that councilman
malvezi mentioned
um i think the lowest end was 57 000
um and the highest end in the price
differential was 88 000
is that right i actually quoted a
hundred thousand
sorry uh which which page are you
referring to cathartic
sorry in the budget paper i think it's
page 169
um i'm actually looking back now at the
paper that we just considered
um and i think councillor malves is
right we did talk about the greatest
cost differential
99 000 yeah
yeah we've got we've got 89 000 in in
the budget paper
88 thousand sorry yeah i just i just
wanted to make sure that that is the
latest
figure because um the price differential
work was quite late on in
in the day so i just wanted to make sure
that we have got the right figure in
there but i think we have
i think yes we have yeah yeah 88
yes okay yes it will increase running
costs by 88
000. yeah because you've got your
existing
and the increase so we are
budgeting worst case scenario
yep i've just found it actually it's in
the in the hvo report it's a paragraph
6.4
um and it does mention 88 000 in the
general fund yep
yep thanks good okay thanks uh council
busby
thank you chair page 164 8.7
new homes bonus just wonder whether mr
or
catherine could say how accurate were we
in predicting
the amount of new homes bonus that we
were going to receive over the last few
years
and how robust do they think the 835
figure is for
the coming year bearing in mind that you
know we could still be shut down
three months six months into next year
yeah um thanks sir councilman good point
uh catherine
are you able to uh provide an answer
please yes thank you
chair in terms of the 835 that figure is
the figure that's in the provisional
settlement so unless anything changes
from the government between the
provisional and the final settlement
that number is confirmed now
because it's a backward looking rather
than a forward looking
so that that allows for the housing
growth between
october 2019 and october 2020.
okay great so we haven't got to build a
certain number of houses to get that
this year
thank goodness for that thank you okay
thank you
right uh councillor davis yeah um mine's
about the the free swimming
and i totally understand why we've had
to cut it out this year
you know for two reasons really um but
could i have an assurance that um
even with the transformation fund not
being as high as it was
that those three swims and the money
will be found as soon as possible
to um to bring them back certainly in
the next next budget year
yeah i i would certainly like to see
that the free swims was very popular
and certainly now with the the opening
or the imminent opening of the new paul
and hadley although
obviously uh the current lockdown will
have an impact on that
i'm sure that will uh have a huge number
of people wanting to use it
so um yeah i i
would very much expect and and uh hope
that we can
uh reintroduce this in the following
year
um castle now vco oh
uh you've got your hand up did you i
just wanted to
to add to uh counselor davis's comments
about
the free swims um from an environmental
point of view obviously
i would be very supportive because it
adds to the well-being of our community
and her and considering what everybody's
gone through
these past nine months um getting into
future budgets we need to find that
money because we will need
to help families and people to get back
to some normality
and well-being um yeah
right castle holt any questions
uh no i'll come in and debate thank you
okay thanks
castle malvesi do you have any other
questions at this stage
no no thank you councillor osborne
no not at this stage thank you mr
chairman council parker
uh yeah if i can um chair i'll just
with regards to cifco and it probably is
actually an item that will probably come
out in debate as well but
you you know you mentioned that we uh
with with the additional uh
investment uh in cifco we're predicting
an additional income of
i think you said about four hundred and
twenty thousand pounds and in fact
that's shown on
on page one six nine um
now obviously there's a lot of suspicion
out there cifco is always
um a hot topic if you like
my own view is that it's produced to
date 1.6
million pounds worth of income and we're
now projecting something in the order of
2.2 million but
i wonder how assured we can be
uh that our investment strategy is um
is on target with with cifco um there is
a lot of concern out there obviously
that we're investing in in for example
high street properties that are going to
see
a very negative return over the next uh
over the next few years so
i'm just wondering what uh what
assurances we can uh we can give people
on that chair but
as i said it's probably an item for um
for debate
it's probably more of an item for when
we're reviewing the cifco
business plan but um i think
certainly with the investments that
we've been making this year um
they they vindicate the investment
strategy and show that we are
investing in a very diversified
portfolio and it isn't just high street
retail
it is across all of the commercial
sector and
um the the other point uh about it
is that um it is weathering the coveted
storm very well
we are not seeing a significant impact
on our civic investments
so that i think is is excellent
um right so uh before we move into
debate
uh council mccraw do you have any
questions
uh bad news i do chair good news i'll
reserve those questions for the scrutiny
process
on the 18th so none today
okay thank you thank you very much
right then we'll move into debate um
counselor arthi
do you have any comments um yeah it's
not really debate it's a
it's a comment um and it's about you
chairman
um not not only are you leader of the
council
um but also cabinet member for finance
and contrary to some recent comments
from members of the public
you don't draw additional allowances for
the extra role
and we owe you i think a debt of thanks
for taking this on um and making
yourself so familiar with all aspects of
our income and expenditure
i'm amazed when i ask you a specific
question about an element of
our budget um and you invariably
actually know the answer
which which is astonishing so it's
really just to thank you very much a for
taking it on
and and b for being so good at it thanks
well thank you um thank you very much
okay um councillor busby do you want to
say the same thing
well but i'll second it
do you have any uh comments you would
wish to make in the debate
well now councillor arthur said that
you're a wizard answering all the
questions i'm going to have to look
really hard to see if i can find
something to test you
but not at this point we've been through
questions we're in debate now
oh you don't get out of it that easy
council davis no i'll third what council
rather he said
but i've got no further comment thank
you
counselor hole yeah i think just with
the presentation and people who
take time to read through the paper
we'll see what's such a
what what's such a complicated thing it
is i mean
we're cutting 38 000 pound swims we're
having 404 000 put on biodiversity and
climate change
you know we're we're talking about
cutting small things but very essential
things
and fairly large sums of money aside for
other essential things
and i think people understand that this
is a very difficult
process to balance a budget and there
are some hard decisions being taken
and people may not always think that the
right decisions and they may not always
be popular but
it's such a difficult process of getting
it right and i think you are to be
credited with um
with the way you've gone about it and
obviously the officers as well
um we've all had long discussions about
what we think may not happen and what
should happen but um
i think people if they look back and
look at this they'll see what difficult
choices we've had to make
so that's what i want to say at the
moment thank you counselor the real hard
work is done by catherine melissa and
the team
they they are they really put in the
hours over the budget setting process
um they winter is not the time they
can't go off on skiing holidays
they have to be around all the time
through uh december and january
castle malvisi uh thank you mr chairman
um i fully endorse what counselor holt
says
um i'd also like to add to it that as a
cabinet i believe that we have worked
very well together we've had our um
differences shall we say and we've had
our subsequent discussions
on those differences but at the end of
the day
we're trying to pull together
a budget that is difficult it
is complex providing services to a
community
is not an easy feat and i just hope that
those people who
are observing our cabinet meeting
tonight
and um and others who may look at it um
in the days to come that they realize
that
it's not like your domestic finances
it really is complex
and well done to everybody for producing
it
thank you councillor osborne thank you
mr chairman
the problem is by the time you get to me
near the bottom of the list everything i
wanted to say
has already been said but just to
basically reinforce
reinforce what councillor holter said
it's an excellent report the team have
worked very hard
also cabinet members have worked very
hard we've spent many hours over the
last three or four months even
going through all the facts and the
figures and as councillor holt has
already alluded to
we have to make some difficult choices
it really is not easy but that's what
we're here
to do um so it is an excellent report
thank you to you john thank you to the
rest of my cabinet members
and also to the officers for
for their hard work in getting to the
stage that we've got to
can i just mention about the the swims
while we're in debate
i was very disappointed to see that the
swimming lessons
free swimming lessons had to be removed
they fitted very well in with our
priorities which is health and
well-being
i know it was really well received by
many many families
so it is a shame so like like councillor
davis and like councillor may vasey has
already said
i really hope that we can find the
resources to bring it back
when we revisit the budget in 12 months
time
but that's that's it thank you mr
chairman okay
thank you um finally council parker
yeah i just endorsed everything that
everybody said but but i'd also just add
um quickly uh mr chairman as well that
when we say we have to make difficult
decisions we literally
have to make difficult decisions and i i
think this is quite often lost on people
that we have a statutory obligation
to deliver a balanced budget we can't do
anything else
um and so there are some real
pressurized conversations that that take
place
um and um i yeah i i think it's
um excellent work it's been undertaken
by everybody this year um
but it just means that we roll on to the
next one and the considerations
thereafter and and so it starts again
but
um yeah that's all i have to say thank
you jen yeah
and and those difficult decisions
obviously revolve around
charging for our discretionary services
i think what what's
also lost on on quite a number of
members of the public is that
our key income sources and council tax
and business rates
will not cover all of those
discretionary services indeed they're
not meant to
a lot of those discretionary services
are meant to be self-funding um
it's just a fact of life um and
uh obviously can be very controversial
as we've found out
over short-term parking charges even
very modest short-term parking charges
however that's all i'll say on that
particular subject uh this evening
i'll now ask the governor's office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members your vote is now
in progress on the app
hmm
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for that's unanimous
thanks claire right the next item is
paper pca 2020 the draft housing revenue
account
budget avoid your outlook for 2021 2022
so i'm pleased to report to introduce
report bca2020
um for the housing revenue account
budget and four-year outlook
it covers both the hra revenue account
and capital program
it will enable us today to consider key
aspects of the draft budget and make any
recommendations to feed into the final
budget report next month
we have a sound 30-year business plan
which will support our ambitions to
increase our housing stock
and which continues to deliver favorable
positions for both revenue and capital
we've been helped by the ending of the
annual 1 rent reduction imposed by the
welfare and reform and work
and work act of 2016 and the act now
allows
rents to be increased by cpi plus one
percent five years from 2020 to 20
21 the remaining 25 years of the
business plan are based on an annual
rent increase of cpi only
the business plan is attached to
dependents b and shows
detail for years 1 to 10. the new
business plan will be presented to
cabinet and council during this year
as explained in paragraph 4.2 plan will
include the need to invest in
the existing housing stock for
environmental improvements and safety
enhancements
and to build new homes that meet the
draft design guide and an improved new
build specification
we are continuing with our aspiration to
increase our housing stock
new homes of all types provide us with
new homes bonus and council tax
but additional counseling housing also
delivers rental income and wider
financial
and more importantly social benefits
curved 19 has had a major impact this
year construction was halted for
a period and property repairs and
maintenance were reduced to emergency
repairs only
however void work in order to support
the accommodation of the homeless
and rough sleepers continued and the
renovation of the leads in a matter of
days was an excellent example of what
we were still able to achieve
there is also no doubt that rent levels
are being impacted
although in the first half of the
current financial year this was minimal
the full extent of this won't be known
for a while and so we have assumed a 15
reduction for the second half a small
amount of direct covered related cost
has been incurred
47 000 pounds for ppe but this has been
covered by our government's covered
support
there has been no specific support for
the hra from government yet
the details of the budget are presented
in section 5 of the report with table 1
and paragraph 5 and 2 summarizing the
key elements and the movements from the
2020 to 2021 budget
surplus position of 170 27 000 pounds is
forecast
which is the reduction on 2019 to 2020
which had a 334 000 pound surplus
we are proposing to transfer this
surplus to the strategic priorities
reserve
the budget has been based on a number of
assignments the income ones that affect
our tenants being
the 1.5 rent increase which represents
an increase of 1.35 on the average
weekly rental of 91.70
garage rates will be unchanged there'll
be an increase of 69 pence per week for
sheltered housing charges
utility charges will be unchanged other
movements are explained in paragraph 5.5
the largest contribution to the reduced
surplus is the inclusion of 967 000
pounds for depreciation
resulting from a revaluation of the
housing stock
also highlighted here are the key
achievements this year the most notable
being that boys remain at an average of
18 days
and an excellent effort by building
services has resulted in the work in
progress reducing from 7500
to 1500 outstanding jobs
paragraphs 5.659 of the report show the
predicted movement in the reserves the
ambitious capital program will require
funding of 2.617 million pounds from the
strategic priorities reserve
as well as additional borrowing the
result will be a reduction in the
overall reserves balance
to still healthy 13.167 million
pounds table 3 in section 5.10 of the
report summarizes the capital
expenditure and financing for the next
four years up to 2024 to 2025.
an appendix a provides more detail new
bills and acquisitions are forecast to
be 24 million pounds
including a carry forward from the
current year we have worked successfully
with icne to identify sites and are now
proposing an
additional 161 affordable and 44 shared
ownership homes
in the period 2021 to 2024
recently klondike field worsted has been
added to the sites list
finally i would like to note that right
to buy sales have again shown a further
reduction and are lower than those
projected in the business plan
in 2019 to 2020 baber sold only 11
against an original projection of 20
sales
we have been delayed by covert in our
ability to use the right to buy receipts
before deadlines for returning unspent
portions to government
however the government has extended the
deadline to 31st of march in recognition
of this
and we are looking at all opportunities
to acquire houses or land before this
deadline
so i'd like to propose the
recommendations in paragraph 3.1 to 3.7
and may i have a second please
i'd like to write yeah i'd like to
second that mr chairman thank you
okay thank you so
questions from uh cabinet members
counselorathy do you have any questions
um yeah it's just one quick one and it
occurred to me whilst you were
presenting the paper um and you
mentioned um the work that icini were
doing
um on potential sites and i just
wondered whether that included the
garage sites work that we spoke about
quite a lot a couple of years ago but i
don't seem to have heard very much about
it recently we were going through a
comprehensive review of all of our
garage sites
and looking at the ones that were um
unoccupied
um and the ones that might be suitable
for potential
development um so i just wondered if if
that's sort of
um gone off the radar or whether that
work is ongoing or if
the acne work that you mentioned
includes that
um i will either pass it over to the
cabinet member for housing or to
to gavin firstly council osborne do you
um
have any response to that yeah thank you
mr chairman yeah the work is
is continuing on that um they're proving
more difficult
than we sort of anticipated in as much
as
you've got mixed sites where you've got
owner occupiers and then you've got
those that are rented so that's proving
quite difficult
and there are a lot of more um
viable sites coming forward without the
garage site so we've been focusing
our efforts on those to get the delivery
of houses rather than
focusing on garage sites which is
proving more difficult
um so i don't know if i see that um
gavin the
um assistant director for housing i
don't know if gavin if you want to add
to that
uh no chair and no cabinet holder
nothing to add to you've
um you've explained it very well
okay thank you councillor busby any
questions
yes chair page 183 5.18
you we talked about the uh right to buy
being less
and that we've not been able to build as
many of our own homes as we liked
therefore we've
purchased existing homes and suitable
land
i just wondered what the the kind of
strategy is there
how do we decide which homes we're going
to buy because
i mean there's thousands that are
available
um that's a good question gavin
could you come back on on that one
because i know on a number of our key
sites
um we do bid for the affordable housing
quota
yes thank you chair uh thank you uh
councillor bosby for the question
um obviously our affordable housing
program is is heavily focused
on building our our own new homes to our
own standards
as well as the opportunities that
section 106 present currently
there has been the requirement to buy
spot purchases
through uh the means of right move and
others and
um the assets and investments team will
work closely
with the housing team to understand and
identify
both the the type and size of properties
that are in
the most significant demand uh typically
uh
two bed or three bed accommodation um as
well as a need for for smaller flats
in um in certain locations so um
they are giving that task and and the
team will go out and
and try and uh ascertain or find those
suitable properties to to purchase
so do you do you look at the the housing
register
where there's a there's a demand and
then say yeah
look we've got i don't know 100 people
wanting houses in
hadley say we've only got 10 coming
forward therefore we need to go and see
if we can buy some houses and have
is that the approach that you take yes
we will look at demand we will look at
where we
have significant demand within our
district
and the opportunities available in those
locations so
that work does get uh that does take
place
okay thank you thank you council davis
any questions nothing from me uh i'll
wait to the
comments thanks okay council hold
dead yeah just one thing on 5.16
it mentions about the money paid back to
government or the
possibility of money going back to
government if we don't spend it in time
have we ever done that
that has been done um i'm not sure
we get three years by the look of it too
use the money i just wondered if we've
ever failed to use it and we've had to
pay it back
well we're certainly in in danger at the
moment
um to be brutally honest about it
counselor which is why we are
frantically
trying to to use up um right to buy
recipes that are due to um
to be paid in the next few months if if
we don't
um the delay or the postponement has
helped us um
otherwise we would definitely have had
to pay some back um
at the end of uh last year last month um
but uh we we are confident that um we'll
be able to reduce
that uh to almost zero there are a
number of opportunities for
for a purchase that we're actively
pursuing
um i i don't know if um
you'd have any comment on on that i
think this
if we were sorry john if we were to pay
it back i think it does put us in a
little bit of a bad light and
if we get three years to use it we
should have a
roland program that would never allow us
to or put us in the position where we
have to pay money back
well you're right and there is a rolling
program
um but uh a lot of it is a matter of um
having the opportunities available so um
it's it's not always
easy to um to to project that forward
uh councillor osborne did you want to
say something about that yeah well
yeah i was just going to answer council
hall's question that there is a role in
review
and we certainly i certainly don't as
the cabinet member for housing want to
see
any money go back to the government when
it's there to provide affordable housing
that's my complete aim for that not to
happen but
the problem that we've got and i know
it's very easy to blame
the current situation and the fall in
that on covid
but it has impacted on our ability to be
able to purchase properties
and to find sites where we can acquire
properties from
so um just to reassure you councillor
whole we are working extremely hard
to ensure as our officers of course to
ensure
that the if we do pay any back to the
government in march i believe it is john
that it will be the minimum minimum
amount and that if it does happen this
year
we will most certainly make sure that it
doesn't reoccur
in the next year i think just one thing
coming back on that i think it
highlights the fact that we've all
discussed that cabinet is that
we need to build our own and we need to
find the land to do that with
and if we were having our own bill that
we were controlling then we were
sure would have a tighter hand on the
finances
can i sorry mr chairman can i come in on
that we have actually
there are some sites that have been
identified to build
our own we haven't completed on them yet
so it's
it's not for in the public forum to to
say where they are
but there are a couple of sites coming
forward uh where we will be building our
own affordable housing to add to our
house in stock
so that is most certainly council hall
being being done as well
thanks castlemovies any questions
um i don't have any questions at this
stage but i do have a comment
in that um counselor holt and
obviously councillor osborne are
highlighting how
um we are working in difficult
circumstances to achieve
um a lot for our community and we don't
get the credit for it
at least the people who are doing it
don't get the credit for it
thank you and i just think that needs to
be said thank you
yeah i agree councillor osborne any
questions
no mr chairman thank you councillor
parker
uh no questions chair thank you
um other counselors council mccraw do
you have any questions at this stage
none at this stage chair
right i'll um now move into the debate
um
counselor arthi do you have any uh
contributions
to the debate that you wish to make um
no thank you chairman no
that's castle busby uh no thanks i've
done my bit
okay castle davis yeah i do actually um
i want to praise the housing team
and on this budget balancing the books
is really difficult
but i'm going to give a first-hand
example of what's going on in shortly
where um houses for us council houses
um are being built as we speak
so despite covid despite the market
despite everything
um our team have managed to get together
we've got two different sites it's only
eight homes but it's eight homes
which i know we're going to be over
subscribed because they're desperately
needed
um and i i think that's a great template
that and and we've seen in other areas
what people are doing so i i i'd give a
chuck up to the uh handsome team
for the way they've managed to to get
this sorted out certainly in shortly and
as
councillor osborne has said in other
areas in the district
thank you councillor hulk
yeah just picking up what council david
said i absolutely agree that uh
it's great to see them being built um i
think i'll come back to my point though
which was
you had need a continuous run of that
because i believe i set on planning at
the time when those were approved
so that must be over two years ago um so
you just need that train to keep moving
along so that we continuously have
these type of projects on stream being
replaced by one another as they as they
get developed
thank you yeah councilmember easy
nothing further to add mr chairman
thank you councillor osborne now just to
um reinforce what councillor davis has
said and to add my thanks to the housing
team
they have done a fantastic job all of
them throughout
the difficult situation facing many many
challenges and they've really come up to
it so
many thanks to the team and also for
those putting the hra report together as
well it's a very good report
thank you and finally castle parker
uh if i can just make the the point
chair for anybody that's listening that
might
might have been quizzing why uh we might
be paying money back to the government
uh and not using that to um to prop up
uh
any any sort of losses or deficits in
the general fund
simple answer is we can't we're not
allowed to just make that point thank
you yeah
that's that's a good point um we should
keep reiterating that the housing
revenue account is a ring fence down
um part of our finances that
takes in revenue from some castle houses
and
and also spends money on those council
houses and um
it cannot be used to supplement or the
general fund and neither can the general
fund be used to supplement the
the hra they are completely separate
ring fence
okay so i'll now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please claire
thank you chair members the vote is
ready for you now
thank you that's eight votes for chair
that's unanimous
thanks claire right item 14 paper bca
2023
allocation and grant of bd baby district
council community sums for lebanon
community land trust
and i'll now ask the cabinet member for
housing to introduce this report
councillor osborne thank you mr chairman
um good afternoon members i'm delighted
to be able to present to you today paper
bca 2023 allocation and grant of babies
commuted sums for 11 and community
land trust both mid-suffolk and baba
district council received
fund funding in 2017 to enable the
district council
along with other local government
organizations to grant support
community-led housing organizations
within our communities
to become established baber district
council has continued to support our
local communities and establish
community land trusts to deliver homes
that are affordable for their residents
and will remain so for future
generations
the community housing enabling officer
within the strategic housing team
works with community organizations in
the district
to achieve this inevitably the biggest
barrier for these newly formed local
organizations
wishing to provide housing within their
communities is access to finance
by utilizing commuted sums the
affordable housing contributions derived
from open market housing developments
the district can
at least help to reduce the debt
liabilities of these local organizations
community land trust would like to
purchase four
of the 106 properties at melford road in
lebanon
they have secured a mortgage to purchase
the units but require 160 000
from commuted sums to cover the short
form
these properties would be allocated to
local people
and held for future generations
allocations of over 150 000 from
commuted sums are designated as key
decisions which is why i would like to
now propose the recommendations set out
in the report 3.1 members note the
content of this report
and 3.2 that members approve grant of up
to 160
000 bdc commuted sums to lebanon
community land trust
as a contribution towards purchase costs
of four affordable homes
from baby district council as discussed
with this
report and um officer heather tucker is
here to answer any questions if i'm
unable to
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you councillor osborne
um may i have a second uh for this paper
please
i'll second it mr chairman thank you
castle
thank you okay questions
counselorathy um no questions thank you
but i i will make a comment
when we come to dubai okay council busby
uh no thanks chair council davis no
questions thank you
councillor holt no thank you councilman
rbc
no thank you mr chairman councillor
parker
uh no questions thank you and
moving on are there any questions from
uh councilman crawd do you have any
questions
no questions chip okay thank you well
we'll move straight into uh debate then
casarathi
yes thank you um we don't hear the word
localism used very much these days
but this is an example of localism at
its best um
these commuted sums are for the
provision of affordable housing
and here we've got four homes um in
lavenam
four homes for local people through a
commun uh commun
oh god can't say a community land trust
and i wholeheartedly support it thank
you
thanks council busby
uh nothing to add councillor davis
no i think i just endorsed what um
council arthur he said um
obviously he he knows that very well
because it's in this ward
but i think it's a marvelous template
that the whole community land trust
um that you know more and more places
around the district
um should look at and and try to um
to to try and at least copy
thank you council hall our district
council to davis find comments
thank you council marvesi i'm just going
to repeat what councillor osborne said
earlier on
another item that everybody said what
i'm thinking
so well done councillor arthi
davis and holt thank you thank you
councillor osborne yeah thank you mr
chairman um just to say well done to
london parish council really and the the
community land trust that's been set up
they've really worked very hard on this
and they already have one very
successful site in lebanon so this will
be in addition to that
and also another good thing about
community land trust
is the properties are not subject to
right to buy
so they're there for future generations
so
well done to lebanon um another good
result for them
and i am glad that baber district
council can be of assistance in this way
to enable them to carry this fantastic
project forward
thank you mr chairman thanks counselor
yeah endorse all of that chair and just
to say that this for me is
is what we exist for as a local
authority um so
very well done to and um excellent thank
you
yeah and uh i'll endorse all of the
comments and and um
point out that lavenham has been very
successful in
in this particular venture um with their
have we lost john or is it just me chair
can you hear us oh well i'm here
i'm sorry chair we lost you for a minute
then
did you yes i i'm back can you hear me
yes we can hear you now thank you
right well i was just saying that um uh
le
lavrom have a wealth of experience um in
this
and um just to encourage other
communities to to talk to them
and um have you still got me
yes yes
i think there are people on your roof
pulling wires out as we speak though
well um let's let's move on to the uh
electronic
vote then um i'll ask the governor's
office to conduct the vote please
thank you chair members the vote is now
ready
thank you that's um eight votes for
chair
thanks claire right we're on the home
straight now
um item 15 is the resolution to exclude
the public
which uh includes the press and so to
consider whether pursuant to part one of
schedule 12a of the local government act
1972
the public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds on the grounds if the
public were present during this item
it is likely that there would be the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against the item the author
of the report proposed to be considered
in part two of the agenda is satisfied
that the public interest in maintaining
the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information
so do i have a proposal please
may i have a proposal yeah i'll propose
it john
thank you and the second is that
councilors born second
yes mr chairman i'm happy to second it
thank you
okay um we now have to have a vote on
this so i'll ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote please
thank you chair the vote is in progress
members
okay thank you we have seven votes for
and one abstain
chair okay we just wait and rob will
confirm when the live stream has
been switched off
you